Hello, I'm Alex Villareal with VOA 60 America for January 9th.
The US military is investigating two deadly crashes that occurred within 24 hours.
The Navy says two of five sailors aboard a helicopter that crashed Wednesday...
...during a training mission off the coast of Virginia have died, and one is still missing.
Two other sailors are being treated for injuries.
Another helicopter crashed during a training exercise in Britain Wednesday,...
...killing all four crew members.
A scandal continues to unfold as New Jersey Governor Chris Christie says...
...it is unacceptable that his aide allegedly orchestrated traffic mayhem...
...to pursue a political vendetta.
Finally, retired American basketball star Dennis Rodman apologized...
...for an incoherent, profanity-filled rant...
...in which he appeared to blame a US citizen for being held by North Korea.
State Department and White House officials have stressed...
...that Rodman's trip to North Korea was not sanctioned by the US.
That's all for today.
Thanks for watching.